For all the action, mistakes, easter eggs
and cameos in blockbuster movies, the drama
and comedy behind the scenes can be just as
awesome. We're changing things up, and giving
you another rapid fire dose of movie trivia
you never thought to look for. Screen Rant
presents: Know Your Movies: 20 Amazing Movie
Secrets That Will Blow Your Mind #2.
The Revenant
The director's commitment to realism didn't
just send the cast into the wild, but scenes
could only be filmed using natural light,
with the crew waiting until the sun lit the
scene perfectly, and having just hours to
shoot each day.
Star Wars: The Force Awakens
The Stormtrooper Finn gets his nickname from
his First Order ID: FN-2187. The FN stands
for Footsoldier Number, but the 2187 is a
reference to Leia's Death Star prison cell
in the first movie.
Mad Max: Fury Road
Fans hoping to see a romance develop between
stars Max Rockatansky and Furiosa left the
theatre disappointed. But the doubles for
Tom Hardy and Charlize Theron didn't. While
they rehearsed the brutal fistfight between
the two characters, they fell in love, eventually
marrying once production wrapped.
Avengers: Age of Ultron
Scarlett Johansson didn't know she was pregnant
until a day before filming started, so the
Ultron effects team was charged with hiding
her growing belly through CG. Aside from stunt
doubles, watch out for Black Widow covering
her stomach, or conveniently lying down for
entire scenes.
The Martian
A lot of the humor in this Mars story comes
from the book it's based on, but the filmmakers
had some fun. In one scene, the head of NASA
makes an accurate prediction. It's accurate,
because that exact scene played out in the
novel, giving those who read it an even bigger
laugh.
Jurassic World
Nobody would have ever guessed that Chris
Pratt, the chubby clown from Parks & Rec would
wind up battling dinosaurs, right? Wrong.
He made the prediction himself in a behind-the-scenes
gag video four years before being cast.
Minions
The little yellow mascots of the Despicable
Me series are famous for their voices and
gibberish language. But for their standalone
movie, it was only the director Pierre Coffin
who supplied the voices. All of them. All
899 of them. Talk about dedication.
Ant-Man
Even though Adam McKay was brought in to rewrite
Ant-Man, there weren't many connections to
his other hit, Anchorman. But the Pym Technologies
building should look familiar - it's the same
Atlanta building used for the Channel 4 headquarters.
Deadpool
Almost every superhero movie costume comes
with a muscle suit to give the stars a comic
book body. But on Ryan Reynolds, the extra
muscles were overkill, so the finished physique
of Deadpool is all natural.
X-Men: Apocalypse
The mutant Nightcrawler gets a second appearance
in this prequel/reboot, played by Kodi Smit-McPhee.
The actor finally joins the Marvel superteam
after he was originally cast as a young Wolverine,
in X-Men: Origins. He probably made the right
call.
Warcraft
Even though the Orcs of this video game fantasy
are created entirely in computers, director
Duncan Jones still had full-sized models of
their in-game armor constructed to scale,
so the actors knew just intimidating their
CG characters really were.
The Jungle Book
Most Disney movies tend to give animals human
personalities, but for the CG/live-action
Jungle Book, it's the opposite. Footage of
real animals was used as the base, with the
famous cast having to copy those movements
as they delivered their lines.
Independence Day: Resurgence
Can you believe an Independence Day sequel
was actually planned as soon as the movie
hit theatres? The writer wound up returning
his pay for the sequel script, since he didn't
think the story was strong enough.Fifteen
years later, inspiration struck, and the story
for Resurgence was born - set two decades
after the first film.
The Revenant
It wasn't just the cold and snow that star
Leonardo DiCaprio had to deal with, but his
vegetarian diet. When a scene called for the
character to eat mouthfuls of bison liver,
he realized the fake version wouldn't work,
and chowed down on the real thing - admitting
he would never do it again.
Furious 7
Paul Walker's death stunned movie fans, and
forced the makers of the Fast & Furious team
to get creative. Body doubles, CG and Walker's
brothers were used to finish his scenes in
Furious 7. The most incredible solution? An
airplane scene that required the effects team
to copy Walker in, frame by frame, using footage
taken from Fast Five to finish his character's
story in the series.
The Hateful Eight
Though he denied it at first, Quentin Tarantino
eventually admitted that this western was
planned as a sequel to Django Unchained, with
Jamie Foxx's hero one of the snowed-in bounty
hunters. Since audiences shouldn't know who's
good or bad, or going to survive, he eventually
rewrote the script with Django removed.
Mad Max: Fury Road
American movie fans have learned one lesson
over the years: German or Russian accents
belong to villains. Wartime grudges are worldwide:
in both the English and German versions of
the movie, the evil Buzzards speak Russian.
For the Russian cut, their lines were re-dubbed...
Into German.
Star Wars: The Force Awakens
Director J. J. Abrams found a way to pay homage
to every movie in the original Star Wars trilogy
in his sequel, including the iconic environments
from each in Episode 7. The deserts of Tatooine
in A New Hope, the frozen snow of Hoth in
Empire, and the forests of Endor's moon in
Return of the Jedi.
Mission: Impossible - Rogue Nation
J. J. Abrams may only have produced Rogue
Nation, after directing the franchise's third
instalment, but his impact is still felt.
When Ethan Hunt tries hacking an underwater
terminal, it's labeled with the number 108
- which just happens to be the sum of the
famous numbers from Abrams' famous TV series,
LOST: 4, 8, 15, 16, 23, 42.
Spectre
The famous secret society and supervillain
Blofeld finally returned to the modern Bond
movies, but were originally planned to appear
in the first Casino Royale reboot, but replaced
by "Quantum." When the producer who owned
the rights passed away years later, a settlement
was reached, and Quantum was revealed to be
a subsidiary of SPECTRE all along...
Those are some of our favorite mind blowingmoviefacts,
but let us know which ones we missed and stay
tuned for more! And remember to subscribe
to our channel for more videos like this one.